ein waschbär beule und ein schneemann im
frühling insgesamt 24 mit narzissen
geschmückte figuren schwimmen über den
altaussee in österreich es ist der
höhepunkt des jahres für die region und
das größte blumenfest mitteleuropas rund
20.000 besucher bestaunen wir nicht
dieses spektakel so ein festival habe
ich noch nie in meinem leben gesehen
in meinem land sri lanka gibt es solche
blumen feste nicht
ich bin wirklich beeindruckt es ist für
mich das erste mal kleidungen das fand
ich sehr sehr lustig und sehr schön für
eine figur werden mehrere zehntausend
narzissen gebraucht erst am nachmittag
vor dem großen blumenkorso beginnen die
teilnehmer damit die blüten zu stecken
bis in die morgenstunden kann es dauern
bis eine skulptur fertig ist
helga könig hat erfahrung damit seit
rund 30 jahren macht sie beim
narzissenfest mit für sie eignet sich
die narzisse perfekt zum stecken dann
ganz in glockenspiel und der stil
schwerer ist es wie die blüte und
dadurch hängt sie schon drinnen
also wenn man andere blüten nimmt dann
sagt man muster stil sehr lang sein dass
das drinnen im gitter hängen bleibt also
dieses schwierig und mit einer blüte
die region ausseerland-salzkammergut
verwandelt sich im frühling in ein
duftendes blumenmeer die weiße sterne
blüht hier von mitte mai bis mitte juni
für die figuren werden die narzissen von
hand gepflückt das pflücken schadet den
pflanzen nicht im gegenteil so bleibt
der blume mehr kraft zur fortpflanzung
für das nächste jahr
damit die blüten frisch bleiben müssen
die teilnehmer auf einiges achten
bei den flügen ist einmal ganz wichtig
dass man maximal drei tage davor drückt
kühl lagert dass die blüten nicht nass
werden weil dann ganze braun und dann
halt dass man relativ schnell
verarbeitet hochbetrieb bei den
vorbereitungen viele freiwillige helfen
beim stecken mit dabei gilt die regel
immer drei bis vier narzissen blüten
werden zu einem bunt zusammen genommen
und in ein loch gesteckt so haben sie
mehr halt elisabeth sourcag ist für das
fest aus der nähe von wien angereist für
die narzissen die partnerin geht damit
ein kindheitstraum in erfüllung
wir haben dann heute schon in der früh
umgepflügt es war auch sehr schwierig
sich gehabt und so und heute damals dann
hergebracht und die haben sich gefreut
obwohl die blumen ja gar nicht mehr so
perfekt waren aber jetzt haben wir
gesteckt das eine tolle erfahrung und
gemeinschaftsgefühl
normalerweise müssen die figuren aus
mindestens 70% narzissen bestehen dieses
jahr wurde die regelung wegen einer
schlechten narzissen ernte gelockert
deshalb dürfen auch andere blüten wie
margarethen oder auch naturmaterialien
wie moos verwendet werden
die teilnehmer des stadtkurses in bad
aussee machen das beste daraus
hier werden alle figuren präsentiert
egal ob tier oder fantasiefigur der
kreativität sind keine grenzen gesetzt
wichtig ist es das publikum und eine 20
köpfige jury zu überzeugen
es gibt eine bewertungskatalog der
sieben punkte umfasst das ist von der
dichtheit der nazis begonnen über über
die ganze hand eindruck über die größe
dass sie in sieben verschiedene punkte
und da kann man schon mal abwägen in
welche richtung ist war von der
platzierung ungefähr geht am ende
gewinnen die eule der waschbär und der
clown erste preise im rennen um die
schönste narzissen figur runde formen
sind bei der bewertung im vorteil da sie
schwieriger zu stecken sind das allein
reicht aber nicht für den sieg
meine präsenz verfahren dass das was
lustiges ist was fröhlich es ist das gut
rüberkommt das ganze eigentlich die
gewinnerin der herzen ist und bleibt die
nazis und ihre heimat
die berg- und seenlandschaft des
salzkammerguts